hi Jocko I have read your book extreme
ownership from cover to cover and I
learnt a lot from it
and I have a question that bothers me
the question is how can I be noticed by
the people and get chosen for a leader
okay
good kind of a another question that I
hear you know people get worried that if
they're just kind of putting her head
down and working then they were not
gonna get noticed I don't get noticed I
become a leader stop worrying about
being noticed
hmm that that's number one stop worrying
about being noticed and keep working
hard hmm stop worrying about being
chosen as a leader if your goal is to
get chosen as a leader no work hard
actually work really hard and then put
the team first
so all these thoughts and efforts that
you have around getting noticed and
being recognized instead of having them
focused on being recognized and being
noticed put those thoughts on making the
team successful Wow Wow
put the team first that's what I'm
saying right now with this question
you're actually putting yourself your
self recognition above the team so
instead of thinking about that think
about how you can help the team win and
the more of a team player you are the
more people will want to work with you
the more you help the team win the more
people say I want you on my team
and eventually they say okay you know
what I want you to lead this team
because do you want this team to win so
bad we want you to leave this team
mm-hmm so that is what you do now is
that being said right there's always
there's always a balance because I'm not
saying that you sit back and just keep
your fingers crossed that if you work
hard every someone's gonna notice you
now with this guy who's all worried
about being noticed don't worry about
being noticed you're gonna get notice if
you workout and put your head down but
there's some people that they're there
so they might be so humble that they're
not gonna get noticed for what they're
doing so how do you overcome that well
this doesn't mean that you sit back
your pass if there's a and I'll tell you
the best way to stand out or one of the
best ways to stand out is volunteer
volunteer for everything that comes up
and then crush it the crappy jobs that
no one wants volunteer for those things
that's what I used to see you should see
the young new guys in the SEAL Teams
that's how you tell you get some crappy
job
you walk out to a group of guys going
through training through a bunch of
platoon guys new hey I need three guys
there be like two new guys that would
just be like my other hands would be up
before you could get done say in the
sentence mmm and you just see the look
on their face what do they want to do
they just want to win and you I love
those guys they're just like oh I'll do
that hey hey I need a couple guys to
boom their hands are up you know you
know gonna say go clean the sewer out
they don't care they don't care they're
volunteering for everything ain't no
when I got this when I got to the team
that's what I did volunteered for every
as a matter of fact I volunteered to be
a radiomen because I had heard that it
was a really hard job that no one wanted
I was like okay I'll do that job you got
a job that's really hard no one wants
carrying a heavy weight you don't get to
shoot it right you get to carry an m60
there's a major benefit to that that is
you get to unload massive amounts of
firepower you carry a radio you're just
sitting around with batteries kind of
hardcore in a different way yeah it is
it is and I luckily I got I got told two
things number one that no one wanted
that job and number two that if you were
radio man you'd go on every mission
because they always need a radio man you
know so tell me oh that's me I want to
go on every mission so give I'll take
I'll carry that radio but that that and
everything you use volunteer for
everything so that's that's one of the
best ways that you can make a good
impression is by volunteering for stuff
and then crushing it and eventually
people look at you and they say huh this
guy doesn't care what we give him he's
gonna crush this task and you know what
people like working with him because
he's worried about the team and this
person seems like a blood skip let's
give him a little task and lead
something mm-hmm
because sometimes when you volunteer for
something you're volunteering for
leadership position hey I need four guys
one of those people is gonna be in
charge
hmm right for it's not gonna be four
guys going equally into some thing right
no someone's gonna be with interaction
someone's gonna take charge of it be
that person huh yes good this um when he
said how can I be noticed so to work
hard oh yeah but you know how it's like
okay that's that's what I want I want to
be noticed right so you ever walk into a
bar or something and a girl walks in and
she you can tell she's trying to be
noticed the bad luck man
so what I'm saying is you like if you're
trying to be so people can see that
stuff like this guy's just trying to be
noticed right here understand it does
the opposite obviously that's yeah
you're right that's the hardest thing to
convince of people convince people of is
the fact that if you're just if you're
just working hard you'll get noticed you
will get a noticed it's like um you do
something kind of good or whatever brave
I don't know hey Luke did you guys all
see how brave I was right there no yeah
Brad no one wants you to be leader
it's like saying hey hey guys that task
I did pretty good right I was really
humble no one's no one's more humble
than me no one home with me stop
worrying about you and think of helping
the team in volunteer a bunch and that's
that's where you end up you know in a
leadership position